for the padres jake arrieta glad to see
the 35 year old out there making a
second start as the padre we know that
the first one to colorado fell short
because of the injury well overall this
season 21 starts
opponents the 321 off jake the one thing
that mentioned though his first five
starts of this season he had a nice 2.57
era swings of the first pitch here hits
it out towards deep center field grisham
kind of circling around and he makes the
catch belt buckle high and a quick tidy
one two three top of the first inning
for jake arrieta jose or keaney he is
back as we see the 14 starts this season
for jose your kitty good numbers across
the board it's good to have him back out
there that beautiful strikeout to walk
ratio is nice 66-13 two down here in the
first inning and fernando still at first
base that'll bring up will myers in the
cleanup spot tonight for the padre he's
bare oh it doesn't matter there's jose
keaney throwing a little slider to will
myers and showing a little excitement
coming off the mound as he goes one two
three after the initial walk
one out one on and that'll bring up
trent grisham
strike three called runner on the go
that's a strike about throw him out
double play
joe west makes the call at second base
as martin maldonado guns down austin
nolan in the inning
third in the houston corner against jake
arrieta who has uh cruised for the first
couple of innings one two pitch
and that is strike three first strikeout
for jake garrieta he's retired the first
seven astros tonight one out in the
third inning martine maldonado
fly ball
shallow right over towards the line is
fernando and he'll make the catch for
out number two
and now facing jose or kitty who was oh
for six in his career with five
strikeouts
he does swing there it is jose or kitty
has a base hit
arietta was covering just in case
but her kitty with a line drive single
to right on a 3-1 pitch get the ball
astros want the baseballer keady's
ripping off batting gloves and yeah a
little hang-loose sign to the dugout
jose altuve
on the ground down the third baseline
fair ball machado gets it there without
a problem
so kim and third one out in field in
they shift on the left side tatis junior
drew a walk his first time up
popped up high in the air that's exactly
what our kitty needed jose altuve
underneath it and puts it away that is a
big out for the astros and jose archite
two away and manny machado waiting on a
2-2 pitch from jose or katie
on the ground left side correa's got it
his throw
in time that was close we'll see if the
padre is going to challenge this they
are going to challenge they think
they've scored a run i believe they have
yeah manny says so
safe at first base call over turn padres
have a one-nothing lead
michael brantley has a lead off base hit
here in the top of the fourth inning
here's alex bregman
popped up left side manny machado
is going to step into foul ground and
make the catch for out number one
bradley at second tucker at first one
out lions to center grisham waiting on
it makes the catch build of the cap high
two down first and second with the san
diego leading one nothing the astros
trying to get get something going here
see what correa can do with two outs
swing in a drive center field going back
it's grisham on the track still going
and it's gone
a three run homer for correa and the
astros lead it
3-1
number 21 on the season for carlos
astros desperate
for runs and they lean on carlos correa
again
429 feet to straightaway center field
don't mess with that guy in this
ballpark he is
loving life jake garrieta back to work
going to try and bounce back
from that three-run homer hit by correa
last inning
not strike three second strikeout for
arietta
pitch 63 for jake arrieta of the night
and that is strike three able to strike
out her kd
fly ball center field grisham coming in
to make the catch it ends the inning one
out one on and tommy femme
lying to the gap in left center field
that's going to get down and head
towards the track and the wall
gresham being waved around all the way
from first he will score
it's an rbi double for tommy pham and
it's a one-run game
erickini responsible for fam at second
base here is tatisse for the third time
tonight
on the ground playable yulia will take
it himself
moving over to third is
tommy pham he'll be there with two out
i'll bring up manny machado here's a
payoff pitch
and machado lifts this into right toward
the line going back tucker makes the
catch and the inning draws to a close
two on two down and correa
korea chops one down the left side and
machado hands and gets it there
nice play by manny machado's do or die
on the bare hand
and he gets it done firing to first to
get correa
myers in second hospital first one out
and austin nola
on the ground down the first baseline to
fair ball
from second comes myers he will score
to third goes hosmer this game is tied
at three
second hit of the night for austin nolan
he ties the game two on one away in the
padres seventh and jake cronenworth
coming up so now second and third need a
strikeout he gets one martine maldonado
puts the tag on kronerworth big
strikeout for graben
he got frazier at third and machado at
second
and will myers at first with two away on
the padres seventh inning
got him big strikeout for blake taylor
straining the bases loaded taylor has
been huge pitching in california this
year here's pitch number 10 from pagan
and altuve swings skies it into shallow
center going back hassan kim second
baseman on the outfield grass makes the
catch one away in the top of the eighth
comes michael brantley
line and caught
to the backhand for manny machado for
out number two
looking to do some damage with two out
tucker's 22 home runs
kyle tucker drives one deep to right
field and gone
two run home run kyle tucker
astros take the lead 5-3 in the eighth
that's a big home runs out there on the
left coast
there's a huge one in this ball game too
bringing astro faithful in pekko park to
their feet so now jake myers will get
his second at bad
check swing and that is going to be off
of hosmer in the shallow right field
siri's gonna score jose siri flying
around third crosses the plate
jake
myers brings in a run it's now six to
three astros on a ball that eluded eric
hosmer
presley's 1-1 and that's a bouncing ball
up the middle fielded by altuve races to
second for one throws to first that's
two and that is the ball game